on the very outer limits of the London
sprawl is Oxbridge and South Ruislip
constituency of one Boris Johnson he was
parachuted into this supposedly safe
seat in 2015 but at the last election
things went decidedly off script when
his majority was harmed if he loses it
will be the first time in more than a
century that an incumbent Prime Minister
has been unseated so could it happen I
think he's doing
I vote for him last year last election
and then our poor day again this year I
don't think much what does she think
that he's a silly man how are you
daughter six I do believe he's the right
person for the job
I just need think he's got an impossible
situation he's never going to please
everyone
he's got to do the best that you
possibly can and if the people want to
leave then that's what he's got try and
do bluntly I'm not a big fan but let's
see what happens you know I think he's
trying his best to get bridgett done
whether it should be done is a different
question do you think it should be done
I'm marina we just hear in Uxbridge
today and Boris Johnson's constituency
front of me that filthy piece of toe rag
this one's safe conservative seat is
changing rapidly with an influx of
students and young families the white
British share of the population has
fallen 16 percent in the last decade to
51 percent one of the fastest increases
in ethnic diversity in the country this
all helps the Labour candidate Ali
Milani
at the last election of 40
constituencies with 40 percent ethnic
minority vote 39 or won by labour only
can we win the seat but we we have to
win this seat and part of the reason is
because I think people in this
constituency and people all around the
country are looking for a very very
different kind of politics that tired of
this born to rule Etonian sort of Boris
Johnson's who kind of feel like that
they belong in the palaces of
Westminster and how much support and
resources are you getting them we've had
extraordinary support I mean we we are
campaigning almost every day we've had
people from Brighton from Glasgow from
Nottingham coming
Wrentham is that the Labour Party who's
helping its everyone I mean the
extraordinary thing about having Boris
Johnson as your opponent is it has a
unique way of unifying people we have
people who are not members of the Labour
Party who are local residents who come
out and help us deliver leaflets and
knock on doors so I think in terms of
resources there is no work no denying
the fact that just like a Conservative
Party nationally we will be outspent
here but what they can't capture what
they won't never be able to match us on
is the energy and passion of people here
and the people who have just had enough
but your background hasn't been
unblemished either has social and you've
certainly and gone into some trouble for
things that you original social media in
the past I'm talking about around 2012
on Twitter you wrote know you wait mate
it will cost you a pound hashtag Jew you
said that Israel had no right to exist
you said the land was built on ethnic
cleansing and colonialism oppression is
something your people should know about
yes so look people can have some real
concerns about these things absolutely
and I have tried to do my best in this
campaign and on every public platform to
be completely honest and open about this
kind of thing I have unreservedly
apologized and I do so again what I want
to see the Labour Party do is not only
eradicate anti-semitism from our party
but from society as a whole and so we
absolutely could be doing more you know
it breaks my heart because and I tell
you this because I'm someone who has
faced more racism than most people can
imagine I've had death threats through
my letterbox campaign in this campaign
but the Boris Johnson Stardust may be a
little harder to shift analysis by in
Warren of election data predicts the Lib
Dems will take votes from both
conservatives and labour at the election
but Boris Johnson will hold on other
pollsters agree I think it very unlikely
that Boris Johnson would lose Oxbridge
and one thing that matters a lot
actually in a lot of these close contest
seats is incumbency and clearly he is
the incumbent the the Labour candidate
is not very well known it's going to be
very hard for him to get a campaign up
and running but that said I mean that
the Tories mustn't be complacent there
are a number of more remaini seats than
Uxbridge where I think that they will be
vulnerable probably to a Lib Dem
challenge so yes and of course he's
going to lose seats in Scotland as well
having spent the day in Uxbridge it
feels that Boris Johnson can be fairly
confident of holding the seats at the
next election but because of demographic
changes this constituency seems on a
journey to becoming labour and the
problem for the prime minister at that
election is that there are other seats
already further along that road the
campaign to unseat Boris Johnson is up
and running in Oxbridge
but despite the historic prize there are
other seats with rapidly changing
demographics that could be more
vulnerable at least this time around
Sofia Ridge Sky News Mansbridge